get your hands on
you're taking me somewhere to kill me no i'm
taking you someplace to talk well i don't
like to talk but you do like to lie which you
just did because we both know you love to talk
how long have you been here i don't
know it's hard to say you know time
passes differently here in the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up
glorious
brother, heimdall
you'd better be ready
come on what did you expect
and speaking of fan favorite characters loki the
god of mischief will step out of his brother's
shadow and into his own series on disney plus in
may of next year the great tom hiddleston returns
as loki and is joined in the series by owen wilson
Mbatha-Raw sophia di martino Wunmi Mosaku
and richard e grant as with our other shows coming
to disney plus we want to try something a little
different explore a new genre for us at marvel
studios so we've put loki in the center of his
own crime thriller if that sounds a little unusual
or confusing don't worry loki is just as confused
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new marvel loki trailer for the avengers
end game spin-off series on disney plus there's
so many easter eggs in this obviously it ties
in with thor 4 love and thunder and a bunch of
other mcu movies so i'll explain what's going on
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i will be doing
videos for all the episodes it will be premiering
in may after the black widow movie hits theaters
but just getting into the easter eggs the series
begins with that scene of avengers end game when
iron man thor the avengers lose the tesseract
in the space stone because hulk no like stairs
stairs are probably going to be the villain of
the next hulk movie when marvel gets around to
working their problems out with universal and
they can make another hulk movie but then loki
manages to snag the tesseract and escape so
the main version of loki is still dead after
avengers end game they're not walking that back
he still sacrificed himself gained some redemption
trying to stop thanos from killing thor and
stealing the space stone this loki is now
an alternate reality loki who never experienced
the events of thor the dark world thor ragnarok
or avengers infinity war so all that character
development has not happened for him yet i love
this first scene though where he wakes up at the
end of the space dome portal he uses to escape
and i know the visual effect makes it look like
he's traveling across the universe really he's
just traveling across the earth because as you may
have guessed this is literally and metaphorically
meant to be a scene referencing the iron man
scene of him escaping the cave in iron man 1
he wakes up half buried in the sand after escaping
from a really dangerous situation it's just the
twist is that it's a villain escaping from the
heroes it seems like based on the clothing of the
people that find loki buried in the sand this is
mongolia and he's waking up in the gobi desert in
china but because loki is an anti-hero during the
series that means that the villains he's facing
have to be even worse and i'll get into that
because i believe they're going to get super meta
with this because the showrunner is actually one
of the former writers of rick and morty so it's a
very rick and morty style alternate reality time
travel style series even though technically rick
and morty is not a time travel show they did do
time travel during rick and morty season 4 so they
kind of actually opened that door also a lot of
big doctor who easter eggs in this too because of
the time variance authority that i'll talk about
because that's basically where we go to right
after this but then we jump to the interior of the
time variance authority base where loki has the
voice over thinking they're taking him somewhere
to kill him notice the amazing architecture the
time variance authority are kind of like the time
cops or the time lords of the marvel universe if
you want to make doctor who references they police
all the different timelines not just any one
single timeline so they're a bunch of main branch
realities alternate timelines when a time travel
villain or a multiverse villain in the marvel
universe starts messing with the different branch
timelines that they've sanctioned they step in
to arrest them loki popped on their radar when he
created the new branch reality with the infinity
stone i know this raises lots of questions about
kang the conqueror and the mcu because he's
the biggest marvel time travel villain and he's
also from the distant future he's also the main
villain of ant-man 3 quantumania they finally
confirmed the title and confirmed that this
actor is playing kang the conqueror during that
so some of the loki series will also probably
help set up ant-man 3 in addition to thor 4 love
and thunder because loki will show up during
thor 4 after the events of this series so i'll
talk about the thor easter eggs as we go along
through the footage then we finally get our first
scene with owen wilson who seems like he's playing
loki's main handler at the time variance authority
during the series this scene of the armored men
then entering the tent is just another patrol of
time variance authority soldiers this is what
their armor looks like this scene of the other
tva soldier taking his helmet off looking like
he's getting killed by this hooded figure that's
burning the lamp in the field actually seems like
it's supposed to be female loki played by this
actress we get a better look at her later in the
trailer so i'll talk about that in a second too
but the reason why i think this is female loki
is because right after she takes out this guard
seemingly kills him they dip to black and then
transition up of the scene of loki looking at
himself in this many faceted mirror because she's
a different aspect of loki from the multiverse
and i believe this mirror is meant to foreshadow
the other versions of loki that we're supposed to
see during the series in addition to the female
version of loki i believe there's supposed to be
a kid version of loki from the comics and then
richard e grant is rumored to be playing what
they're describing as classic loki like an even
more evil version of loki that feels more like the
og loki from walt simonsen's classic thor comics
then he says one of his trademark phrases glorious
which is a nice callback to the first avengers
movie i am burdened with glorious purpose then
they take him to face judgment in front of this
tribunal notice the masks this is a nice easter
egg i think for kang the conqueror that has many
different aspects from different parts of the
timeline as well as the three different faces of
the living tribunal which was actually a character
for a hot minute in avengers infinity war and end
game it looks like Gugu Mbatha-Raw is playing the
administrator passing his sentence i'm not sure
if she's playing a pre-existing marvel character
or if they made up a new one for her the tva as
an organization mostly shows up in the fantastic
four comics in the thor comics but they don't show
up a lot and they're not that many big characters
within that organization so she might just be
somebody new that they created for the show
also just a reminder they announced that they're
developing the rebooted mcu fantastic four movie
with the spider-man far from home director
rory he directed all the mcu spider-man films
john watts kang the conqueror is a big avengers
villain but also a big fantastic four easter egg
because his real identity is nathaniel richards
the descendant of reed richards mr fantastic of
the fantastic four so don't be surprised if we see
a whole bunch of fantastic four easter eggs during
the loki series as well then owen wilson shows
loki his rap sheet pretty much all of his crimes
this is basically just footage that they copy and
pasted from the first avengers movie then this tva
assault seems like it's happening inside a roxanne
version of walmart like it says roxcart and we see
it show up later in the trailer i'm not sure when
this is but based on the clothing it seems like
it's relatively close to present day the glowing
panels that they're all running out of seem like
the tva's version of time travel portals then you
see someone probably the villain of the series or
one of the villains of the series watching it
all go down on futuristic banks of monitors
then there's another scene of loki dropping
into an elevator helping inspect what seems
like some sort of portal that another one of the
villains has used to escape i don't know who this
girl owen wilson is talking to and what seems
like this church but a lot of you have asked if
this aspect of the devil and the stained glass
window behind them is supposed to be mephisto
i do think that it is a mephisto easter egg but
then we see Gugu Mbatha-Raw's character looking
like she's getting ready to throw down with loki
back around his sentencing he tosses his daggers
another trademark move last time seen during
thor ragnarok then we see what seems like the
burning and broken remnants of planet earth and
the moon the series is supposed to take place on
earth during different time periods and alternate
realities the series is also supposed to be a
crime thriller so it sounds like loki is supposed
to track down the villain or multiple villains
in whatever they're doing probably leads to this
total destruction of the earth and the moon here
and because this female version of loki is sitting
here in the rubble of this post-apocalyptic future
she might be one of the main villains of
the series perpetrating this grand plot then
there's another different scene of loki waking
up in another time period in an alternate earth
probably one of the other biggest easter eggs in
the trailer here is the rubble of the avengers
tower and it looks like the avengers tower
circa avengers age of ultron the newer design
so whatever time point he jumps to in this
scene it's well after the events of those movies
this is the db cooper scene of loki people have
been talking about loki literally becomes the
db cooper of the mcu he stole a bunch of money
then boarded an airplane to escape the airplane
eventually went down but his body and the money
that he stole were never found to this day there
are still many theories about what happened to him
so thor and heindall plucking him out midair using
the bifrost is a clever reference to the db cooper
theories then there's a big montage of a couple
different scenes him fighting all these people
in this modern day version of rocks and walmart
him dancing with these people then him running
through this post-apocalyptic future earth then
his voice over calling for thor and heimdall to
get the bifrost ready brother i hope you're ready
it's hard to tell who these people are that he's
fighting there's a makeshift thrown behind him
here and this scene with the green room that
he's also in seems like it's coming from a
completely different episode somewhere else
in the series like this might have something
to do with the other more evil version of loki
because it looks like there's this bar behind him
some sort of crazy palace then obviously there's
the president loki easter egg vote loki obviously
we just had a big election in real life so i'm
not surprised that they went for this easter egg
it's right out of the recent comics he's even
wearing the exact same outfit and i love the
way that he's wearing those funny-looking fake
horns they kind of did that during the wandavision
series with them wearing halloween costume
versions of their classic comic book costumes
my other favorite easter egg from this scene too
in the background is the polybius arcade machine
in the background if you don't know about the
legend of polybius it's an urban legend that
emerged in the early 2000s concerning a fictitious
1980s arcade game but like i said it seems like
loki is coming off as both the hero and the
villain of the series the other versions of loki
being the villains i'm assuming there's going to
be a chris hemsworth thor cameo scene to bridge to
thor 4 love and thunder maybe also doctor strange
easter egg and crossover for doctor strange 2 and
ant-man 3 for kang the conqueror and because it's
a thor based series expect other characters from
the thor movies to cameo maybe even idris elba's
heimdall may be sif because she's also coming back
for thor 4 as well either way i can't wait to see
the series obviously i'll be doing episode videos
for everything there are so many other marvel
trailers from the weekend for all the disney
plus series and announcements about the movies
so i will do all those videos as soon as possible
as long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those when i post them
but just a big reminder that the next big marvel
series is going to be Wandavision those episodes
will start january 15th so all that'll start
spinning up after the mandalorian season 2 finale
my video for that will post next friday just like
normal you guys have no idea 2021 is going to be
so much better than 2020. while you wait for
everything click here for my brand new mandalorian
season 2 episode 7 video and click here for all my
other marvel trailers and star wars trailers from
that big disney investor day thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!